Crusp sunshiny weather heralds the inauguration
of the 32nd President of the United States some
spectators were waiting since dawn to feel the
spectacle despite the chilly capital weather all
the trappings consistent with the presidential
incoming are available and everyone who can
possibly make it goes to Washington leaving
Blair House the Truman's and vice president
Barkley are greeted by an enthusiastic crowd
as they start down the mile-long stretch of
Pennsylvania Avenue leading from the White
House to the Capitol building people hang
from the rafters to attend this Democratic
unveiling of the Truman pair Deal policy
or 29 minutes the United States has been without
a chief executive the president's term expired
at noon under the Constitution and necessary
delays halted the ceremony as the world pauses
to await the attitude toward international
policy as pronounced by the chief spokesman
for the United States the group a trifle late
to be sure arrives at the sea mr. Truman vice
president Park Lee and other members of the
official party approached the inaugural stand
fronting the capitol building this is a new page
in American history and the audience attends in
silent reverence as the sacred oath of office is
administered by Chief Justice Fred M Vinson you
will faithfully execute the office of President
of the United States but I will faithfully execute
the office of President of the United States and
will to the best of your ability and whether the
best of my ability preserve protect and defend
the Constitution of the United States preserve
protect and defend the Constitution of the
United States so help you God so help me God
the president takes the opportunity to condemn
communism the honor which the American people have
conferred upon me I accept it with a resolve to
do all that I can for the welfare of this nation
and for the peace of the world in performing
the duties of my office I need the help from
the prayers of every one of you I asked for your
input encouragement and for your support the task
we face are difficult we can accomplish them only
if we work together it is fitting therefore that
we take this occasion to proclaim to the world
the essential principles of faith by which we
live and to declare our aim to all people in
the pursuit of these aims the United States
and other like-minded nations find themselves
directly opposed by a regime of contrary aims
and a totally different concept of life that's
where David here's to a false philosophy which
purports to offer freedom security and greater
opportunity to mankind misled by that philosophy
many peoples have sacrificed their liberties
all the laws of their soul that deceit and
mockery poverty and tyranny are their reward that
philosophy is communism communism is based on the
belief that man is so weak and inadequate that
he is unable to govern himself and therefore
requires the rule of strong message democracy is
based on the conviction that man has the moral and
your capacity as well as the inalienable right
to govern himself with reasons and justice the
initiative desire we are moving on with
other nations to build an even stronger
structure of international order and justice
we shall have as our partner countries which
no longer only contend with the problem of
natural survival are now working to improve
the standards of living of other people we are
ready to undertake new projects to strengthen
a free world seeking for peace and freedom
the president stressed unfaltering support
for the United Nations a program for world
economic recovery and increased world trade
strengthening of peace-loving nations against
aggression through such treaties as the North
Atlantic agreement and the Western Hemisphere
pact and making United States scientific and
industrial progress available to other free
peoples who are now living in conditions
approaching misery steadfast in our faith in the
Almighty we will advance for the world where land
freedom is secure to that end we will devote our
strength our resources and our firmness of resolve
with God's help the future of mankind will be
assured in a world of justice harmony and sea
mr. Truman's message is hailed by a receptive
audience following the inaugural ceremony the
president leaves the capital flanked by his
battery D buddies acting as an honor guard
upwards of 1 million Washington residents
and visitors see Harry Truman's triumphal
procession with Vice President parsley
to the White House reviewing stand this
is Harry Truman's day the day of the political
underdog the day of a man who threw cream curry
rallied a free nation behind him at the pole
from trim West pointers on every branch of
services in the line of March to do him honor
for on this the most elaborate inaugural in
our history the nation pauses to pay homage
to a farm boy who typify the greatest of all
democratic traditions by rising to the highest
office in the land fittingly enough it falls
to the Missouri float to head the parade of
state exhibits in the seven mile procession
campaign enmities are forgotten as Dixiecrat
states and their floats to honor the leader
of therefore he America has a new president its
32nd elected in the tradition of a free people
the might of America its resources its hopes
and confidence lie behind their choice this is
the way of democracy this is the way of a people
who won their freedom the hard way it is a way
of a people who will put their trust in harry s
truman and alben Barkley in the for years to come